We Begin here with news breaking
overnight Russia is blaming Ukraine for
a truck bomb that caused a major fire to
erupt on the only bridge that links
Russian Annex Crimea to Russia
authorities say part of the bridge
collapsed overnight
Russia's foreign Ministry said Ukraine's
reaction to the bridge collapse shows
quote their terrorist nature Russia has
used the Strategic bridge to transport
weapons for its war in Ukraine Charlie
dagada is in Ukraine with the very
latest on this Charlie good morning
good morning to you this is a major
escalation this morning Moscow had
threatened Keith with reprisals if that
bridge was attacked one military analyst
called it a punch in the face for
President Putin on his 70th birthday
images all over social media this
morning show the Kurt's bridge to Crimea
in Flames the Railway Bridge Ablaze and
a section of the parallel Road Bridge
collapsed into the sea Russia State
media blamed a blast on a car bomb a
spectacular explosion setting fire to
seven Railway oil tankers just after 6
a.m the bridge is the only link to
Crimea from the Russian Mainland a hated
symbol of Russia's illegal land grab
since 2018 when President Vladimir Putin
personally drove a truck across it at
the official opening the bridge and
Crimea as a whole was thought to be
beyond the reach and capability of
Ukrainian forces but the past two months
has seen a series of attacks on Crimea
and the Ukrainian government has
repeatedly vowed to take the peninsula
back it comes as Ukrainian forces take
ever more territory in the East and the
South toward Herzog in nightly addresses
president zielinski reading out
recaptured towns like a shopping list
yet Russian forces are fighting back to
pummeling the front-line city of Bak
moots in the Don bass region and
launching long-range missiles into
residential areas like the attack on the
apartment Block in zappariza where the
death toll has now risen to 14. more
innocent victims of Putin's War
president zielinski said Ukrainian
forces have recaptured roughly a
thousand square miles of territory since
this recent counter-offensive began an
area roughly the size of Yosemite
National Park Dana
all right Charlie thank you